il se lance pour une deuxième fois à 77
ans bernie sanders tentera à nouveau de
devenir président auj adversaire
d'hillary clinton pendant les primaires
de 2016
le sénateur indépendant du vermont a
surpris l'élite du parti démocrate en
suscitant un grand engouement notamment
auprès des jeunes électeurs le 2 contre
les changements climatiques
gratuité scolaire jusqu'à l'université
et assurance santé universel aux people
the white nar prévoit que ces
propositions sont toujours au coeur du
discours de ce politicien qui
s'affichent comme socialiste
mais cette fois-ci bernie sanders n'est
plus seul à défendre ses politiques dans
la course
ils sont maintenant 12 démocrates dont
six sénateurs une liste qui pourrait
encore s'allonger taxe sur les très
riches à l'assurance santé pour tous
d'autres candidats tentent aussi la main
aux membres plus à gauche du parti
si certains comme la californienne comme
à l'arrêt ce tient néanmoins à se
dissocier de l'étiquette socialiste
d'autres comme la sénatrice du minnesota
et miquelon butcher n'hésite pas à
rejeter certaines propositions par
exemple la gratuité scolaire
il n'y a pas de solution magique selon
elle entre le centre et la gauche le
débat est déjà relancé sur la meilleure
manière de rallier plus grand nombre
d'électeurs et de regagner la maison
blanche
non et le strain tout comme plus tard
robben impuissant 2 n'a pas de doute il
évoque une révolution qui doit être
complétée au delà de ses idées le
sénateur du vermont pourra compter sur
sa notoriété peu de ses adversaires sont
aussi connu que lui
une situation qui pourrait évidemment
changer si l'ex vice président joe biden
choisi lui aussi de se lancer